[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde
je vais commencer par une histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un bananier
alors vous avez entendu ce travail dans
les plans c'est l'histoire d'un bananier
qui poussait dans la cour de la maison
dynamique et dans la salle elle se
reconnaît
cette armada nevada que là et il jouait
son rôle
est un jour où elle nettoyer sa cour
elle a déplacé un peu alors c'est pas
cette image laissée pour illustrer l a
déplacé impôts comme celui que nous
voyons là est la vie au pied du bananier
mais ce qu'elle savait pas c'est que là
où elle a déposé le pot il y avait un
jeune va gagner et je ne pousse qui
commençait à croiser
voilà ce jeune blanc qui se retrouve
sous ce pot qui pour lui est un obstacle
quasiment insurmontable
c'est une histoire que j'ai vécu dont je
peux attester de sa véracité pour ces
jeunes plants se retrouvent leurs
dessous
il avait le choix soit de dépérir soin
d'essayer de s'en sortir
il va choisir une façon très singulière
de pousser
alors qu'un plan de bananier poussant
auteur lui va commencer à pousser en
épaisseur au lieu de brandy vers le haut
il va s'épaissir il va devenir de plus
en plus robuste on compte plusieurs
endroits sous le pot il va devenir une
masse très dur qui va réussir à soulever
un petit coin du coc laissant ainsi
apparaître deux petites feuilles et
c'est le jour où mon ami a vu ses deux
petites feuilles qu'elle m'a appelé et
qu'elle montre cette histoire
voyant les deux petites fait elle a
soulevé le pot est nickel site était sa
surprise de voir une masse c'est un
bananier 100 a gagné
absolument bizarre mais ça n'a pas
empêché qu'il était vivant et qu'il a
réussi à survivre tout comme ce grand
obstacle qui était en fait en obstacles
qu'il devait la mener à l'échec total
j'aime cette histoire ça fait trois ans
que je l'avais vécu mais j'aime bien le
rappeler cette histoire parce qu'elle
illustre très bien la plata cité colonna
a surmonté des obstacles qui au
demeurant sont insupportables
cette histoire illustre la capacité
qu'on l'a de continuer à se développer
dans des conditions absolument
défavorable
cette histoire illustre la notion de
résilience et c'est ça que je veux
parler ce soir
cet après midi
nous sommes dans une ère très
particulière
depuis deux ans le monde entier ploient
sous la pandémie c'est très compliqué on
sait pas où on vint est depuis plusieurs
années on nous parle du réchauffement
climatique
un des speakers on a parlé tout à
l'heure
les conséquences de ce réchauffement
climatique sont un homme pâle sur la
capacité de survie des espèces neiges
des humains
face à tout cela la nature et la sont
appelés à faire at her à faire preuve
d'une adaptation très intelligente et
très rapide face à tous ces changements
c'est ce qu'on appelle la résilience
je suis un père viginie figure comme on
vous l'a dit tout à l'heure on vous va
donner des titres très pompeux mais je
veux répéter mais avant de les répéter
je veux dire que je suis camerounaise et
quand vous tous vous attend la finale de
la can pendant une toile d'ivoire
avec un score de 2 à 1 en faveur du
cameroun
[Applaudissements]
alors comme je disais j'ai un titre
assez longue un peu pompeux pomme de
kaboul est
docteur en pathologie végétale
épidémiologie moléculaire
j'aime répéter ça parce que c'est une
longue histoire
attendre quatre ans j'ai eu mon doctorat
ce jour là je me souviens
quand le jury a fini de délibérer ils
sont venus c'était dans une école
doctorale en france ils sont venus ils
ont dit cette phrase assez bizarre dans
cette époque doctorale on avait décidé
pour ne donne plus de notion
mais apprendre l'excellence du travail
comme à lens 2 vient de nous présenter
nous allons à l'unanimité décidé de lui
donner la mention très honorable et on
ne s'est pas arrêté là on a ajouté deux
sous les félicitations du jury
j'en parle avec beaucoup d'émotion mais
vous comprendrez pourquoi
c'est une très longue histoire mais nous
allons d'abord revenir à notre bananier
part je disais donc tous les bananiers
nude et l époque était posé sur lui se
bat daniela avoir une trajectoire banal
il allait grandir il allait fleurir il
allait porter un régime qu'ils allaient
nourrir la famille de mon ami et on
allait le coupé parce que c'est sur la
trajectoire d'un bananier
mais les choses ne se sont pas passées
comme ça l'histoire de ce banane et
ressemble à ma vie
plus jeune je réussissais sans aucun
effort
enfant mon père l'avait raconté cette
jolie histoire où un vieil homme lui a
dit il faut épouser la femme cette femme
est enceinte d'une fille dont l'étoile
va briller sur ses terres c'était moi
dans mon jeu n'est dans cette ambiance
avec la certitude que je doit briller
sur ses terres
et j'avoue que je brillais
je réussissais sans effort alors est ce
à cause de la parole de ce monsieur j'en
sais rien et je brillais à 17 ans
j'arrive enfin en europe avec une bourse
d'excellence reconnu aux meilleurs
étudiants au meilleur élève et la bourse
était couvert les études universitaires
et mes premières marées comme je dis je
brillais je pouvais aller danser le
samedi dormi toute la journée de
dimanche allait composer le lundi et
avoir une autre exception dont pour voir
si c'était banal et puis un jour
patatras
je ne peux pas dit quand ça a commencé
je ne sais pas dit comment ça a commencé
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'un jour
j'ai connu un échec
palpable dans tous les domaines et
chaque académie échec social échec
affectif je me suis retrouvé fragilisé
désargenté totalement à la ramasse en
europe et la bruyante gens friqués
parisien dix ans plus tôt à rentrer au
cameroun sans diplôme et à 27 ans je
suis reparti à la l'université là où
j'avais laissé mes études
le pot effet sur ma vie
tout contenu j'ai repris mon courage et
j'ai essayé
j'ai essayé à tel point que je suis
arrivé jusqu'à la fin avant la soutenant
du diplôme d'ingénieur mais pas sa trace
mais notre sont volatilisés dans les
ordinateurs
en fouet la grande foule les notes on
les retrouve pas puis quelque chose sur
place mais note surgissent comme du
rhône sais pas comment mais patatras
cela nuit on voit l'ordinateur avec nos
mémoires
c'est l'histoire du pot sur le bonne
amie c'était je savais pas ce qui
m'arrivait les choses qui m'arrivent
était il expliqué il expliqué en tout
pas bizarre
voilà l'histoire de bananier qui se
retrouve coincé c'était ma vie
je me suis posé des questions je me suis
demandée
par quel bout prendre ma vie
ce que je sais c'est que j'étais perdu
et spacek j'avais honte pourquoi j'avais
honte j'avais mon protégé l'espoir de ma
famille je suis l'aînée d'une fratrie
très chaleureuse et j'étais leur modèle
leur exemple quand je reviens quand je
me retourne dans cette situation c'est
une honte pour la famille c'est honteux
pour la nation parce que les bourses
d'excellence on voulait donner point de
nous former et remédie travailler pour
faire avancer le pays et j'avais honte
pour moi même je me disais j'ai les
capacités de réussir
donc si je ne réussis pas c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose que je ne fais pas bien de
toute façon le plus simple avait aurait
été d'abandonner
mais je me suis dit j'aurais bien me
poser des questions mais le plus
important c'est de trouver des réponses
je veux bien identifiés mais problème
mais si je n'ai pas la solution je vais
pas m'arrêter ya un farceur plaît dans
ma vie je suis croyante
et je pense que nous l'avons pas été
créé au hasard je crois que chacun
d'entre nous à un but particulier sur la
terre je pense que nous sommes dans un
une aisselle de bateau collectif et que
chacun a un rôle à jouer
les chefs d'une personne c'est l'échelle
d'une collectivité et je crois pas c'est
yves nous n'avons pas le droit d'échouer
je veux parler de la résilience
nous rencontrerons toujours des instants
précieux notre chemin
mais le plus important ce n'est pas de
se lamenter mais c'est de chercher à
s'en sortir
pourquoi la résilience c'est quoi c'est
la capacité à contourner des obstacles
la capacité à trouver des plans b parce
qu'il y en a toujours deux chercheuses
issue de secours même quand toutes les
portes se ferment pour moi c'est ça la
résilier je vous parlais d'un bananier
il n'a pas cherché à comprendre ce qui a
mis le pont près ce qui se passe lui
ceux qui cherchent essaie de survivre la
résilience c'est de chercher à survie
c'est l'instinct de survie c'est de se
dire qu'on ne quitte pas la terre sans
avoir écrit son histoire et j'ai dit
c'est ça qui va porter je me rappelais
des rêves et des espoirs qu'on avait eue
sur moi et je me disais j'ai pas le
droit de laisser la vie mon péché d'un
cerveau sert elle et c'est ça qui me
porte et
j'ai tiré de nombreuses à prendre
de nombreux enseignements de ce qui
m'arrivait
donc voilà résignant s'inscrit dans
cette devise de la ville de paris
j'aime fait de vices que j'ai découvert
il ya quelques années lors des attentats
que certains vous connaissez
fluctuat nec mergitur j'ai pas tout
c'est comme ça qu'on dit c'est
l'expression latine ça veut tout
simplement dire tu peux être battu par
les flots mais tu ne vas pas sombrer
nous sommes comme des roseaux nous
pouvons plié mais nous devons toujours
de regret c'est
ça c'est une de mes philosophie de vie
j'ai tiré de nombreux enseignements j'en
ai tiré 3 en particulier le premier
c'est de ne jamais de ne jamais
abandonner ne jamais cesser de se battre
je vous ai pas dit tout ce que j'avais
et j'ai vraiment eu des choses très
particulière quand on cesse de se battre
c'est qu'on a laissé la vie avoir le
dessus sur nous j'aime bien ce poème d'
assassin
s les williams les ce poème a été repris
par nelson mandela et nous a dit c'est
grâce à ce poème qu'il est resté un
homme debout pendant qu'il était en
prison ce poème williams n'est là écrit
alors ta saison venait de lui couper les
jambes et le termine par cette phrase je
suis le maître de mon destin je suis le
capitaine de mon âme un jour je me suis
dit personne ne viendra relever les
obstacles à ma place
personne ne viendra changer la situation
à ma place si je suis le capitaine de ma
vie alors je dois prendre mes
responsabilités
la résilience c'est de ne jamais baisser
les bras deuxième enseignement tôt j'ai
retenu c'est d'être toujours regarder
devant fixer ses objectifs
îles chausey de tomber mais une autre
chose est de se relever mais tant que tu
fixé les yeux si ces objectifs va
avancer je me souviens jours j'avais
fait un champ de tomates et je longeais
la piste d'un aéroport et j'entendais
les moteurs de l'avion entre deux les
réacteurs qui se met en place et je
l'étais du ce jour là j'ai tellement
sillonné le monde aujourd'hui je suis
appelé à passer à travers un aéroport je
suis maintenant du procès court mais un
jour je reviendrai du côté jardin fixé
ses objectifs
et plus tard et c'est bien ce qui va
arriver
je vais faire mon champ de tomates dans
le petit village puis je vais être
recrutés comme chercheur et pendant
quatre ans je n'avais pas de salaire
vous imaginez mais je faisais tous les
petits travaux dans deux laboratoires
tout ce qu'ils avaient à faire je
faisais et un jour alors qu'une équipe
d'américains de france était passée ils
ont de grandes équipes de travail on a
dit c'est elle on a dîné faux calais se
forme aux états unis en france et elle
altère sa thèse et c'est comme ça que
j'aurais ma thèse la résilience et
d'accepter de faire des choses
auxquelles on n'est pas appelée ou
pouvoir s'en sortir c'est de contourner
si je pouvais pas aller tout droit
jallet contourner pourquoi n'y a pas de
sot métier
c'est ça la résilience
plusieurs assauts sur place parce qu'ils
ne veulent pas pour tourner
je dis qu'il ya des choses que j'ai
retenus n'ont jamais baissé les bras
fixer ses objectifs ya une troisième
chose c'est de ne pas abandonner ses
rêves
imaginer quoi quand je me retrouve ce
jour-là repartir aux etats-unis dans un
avion dans le bruit des réacteurs afin
de faire oui oui oui et je me rappelle
quand je traversais l'aéroport pour
aller planter des tomates dans un
village et je me dis pas fausses couches
et ses bons offices a évacué mardi la
marque semble pas de projets proches et
pour moi c'est ça la résilience signaler
un obstacle
il faut continuer à se battre à se bat
jusqu'à dégager leurs styles et toutes
les conséquences de l'obstacle dans ta
vie ma tête c'est qu'à une conséquence
l'échec scolaire est une conséquence des
obstacles mattel a été une façon
d'évacuer reprendre la tête reprendre le
travail c'était évacuer des obstacles
s'était enlevé le pot dessus de moi je
vais parler à quelqu'un de cette façon
d'être je pose pour moi la résilience
c'est de pouvoir refuser la fatalité
c'est de dire il n'y a pas de fatalité
la seule fatalité c'est de cesser de se
battre pour voilà résignant s'est dit
oui à d'autres possibles et même à
l'impossible la croyance que je suis
c'est qu'elles détiennent un jour le
seigneur lui a dit est ce la partie de
cette somme a desséché des des personnes
armées prvi et l'a dit lui la réunion
pour moi c'est à voir cette faculté de
dire oui d'implantation d'un possible
pour moi la résilience est ce que les
croyants appelle la fois
mes proches me définit comme quelqu'un
de très fort de très classe et je salue
mes frères et soeurs pour la confiance
et cette amitié qu'ils m'ont toujours
donné même dans les moments difficiles
j'embrasse aussi mes fils qui sont un
grand soutien pour moi on a défini comme
fort tonnage persévérante et jamais je
baisse les bras mais c'est plus
compliqué que ça
c'est un ensemble de beaucoup de choses
nous sommes le résultat de nos échecs et
de nos réussites nous sommes un
investisseur de nos blessures et de nos
succès voici le résultat de tout ce que
j'ai fait marché et de ce que j'ai fait
était à marcher en je pense pour ma part
qu'un arbre qui a été battue par la
tempête est plus solide qu'un arbre qui
n'a pas de problème je me crois fort à
cause de tout ce que j'ai depuis
et c'est forte de cette expérience que
j'arrive à dire aux personnes qui sont
perturbés dans la vie est gâchée il se
dit c'est fini pour moi je passe pour
celle là qui encourage toujours les gens
parce que la résilience et ça aussi
quand on a les problèmes la tendance à
se replier sur soi-même en vouloir à
tout le monde mais pour ma part être
résilient ont contraint c'est s'ouvrir
aux autres je suis sûr de se baigner
pendant tout grandissait sous le pot qui
permettait à des insectes avaient
formique de pouvoir aussi profité de sa
présence quand on a des obstacles il
faut de vérifier généreux pour voir la
résilience rime avec la bienveillance
je ne pense lure sur ça et je veux dire
à quelqu'un quelque part qui entendra ce
tome
si ça peut l'inspirer je veux juste lui
dire ya pas de fatalité à
chaque situation il faut pouvoir trouver
une solution je vais pouvoir dire à
quelqu'un
quelle que soit la situation et a
toujours devant nous une nouvelle ère
qui peut s'ouvrir alors alors alors
alors comme je le dis toujours aux gens
neva neva n'évoque n'abandonne jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]